So now let's talk about the virtues of this
link list based queuing lock. Some of virtues are
exactly similar to the Anderson's queuing lock, and that
is it is fair. And so Anderson's lock was also
fair, ticket lock was also fair. The linked list
queuing lock is also fair. And again, the spin location
is unique for every spinner, right? Every spinner has
a unique spin location to wait on and so that
is similar to the Anderson's queue lock as
well. And that's good because you're not causing contention
on the network when the lock is released. When
one guy releases the lock, others if they're waiting,
they don't, they don't get bothered by by the,
by the signal. And exactly one processor gets signaled
when the lock is released. That's also good. And
usually, there's only one atomic operation per critical section.
And the only thing that happens is this corner case.
In order to implement this corner case, you have to
use a second atomic operation. But if the link list
has several members in this, in these examples. I'm just
showing only two requesters at a time. But if the
link list has a number of requesters, then if I
am middle of the gang, have, using the lock, I
simply signal the successor. I don't have to do anything fancy
in terms of compare and swap. So this is something
that needs to be done only for the corner case, not
as a, a routine for doing the unlock operation. And
the other good thing that we already mentioned is that the
space complexity of this data structure is proportional to the
number of requesters to the lock at any point of time.
So it is dynamic. It's not statically defined as in
the array-based queueing lock. And so that's one of the biggest
virtues of this particular algorithm that the space
complexity is bound by the number of dynamic
requests to a particular lock, and not the
size of the multi-processor itself. Now the downside
to this link list based queuing lock of course is the fact that there is link
list maintenance overhead that is associated with making
a lock request or unlock request. And Anderson's [INAUDIBLE]
queue lock because it is in a irregular structure
can be slightly faster than this, link list based algorithm.
And one of the things that I should mention
to that is that both Anderson's [UNKNOWN] queue lock as
well as the NCS link list based, queue lock.
May result in poorer performance if the architecture does not
support fancy instructions like this, because they have to
be simulated using test and set, so that can be
a little detriment to to this particular
algorithm as well. We have discussed different
algorithms for implementing locks in a shared
memory multi processor. If the processor has some
form of affection free operation, then the
two flavors of queue based locks, both due
to Anderson and MCS, they are good bet for scalability. If on the other hand,
the processor only has test and set, then an
exponential backoff algorithm would be a good bet for scalability.